hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live der Vogel wurde befreit das hat er
Milliardär Elon Musk getwittert denn er
hat nun die Macht bei Twitter übernommen
der Deal der wurde offiziell bestätigt
vor knapp zwei Stunden 44 Milliarden hat
Musk dafür bezahlt und jetzt gehört ihm
eine der einflussreichsten Plattformen
veröffentlichen Diskurs eine seiner
ersten Amtshandlungen war als das
Personal loswerden CEO Finanzchef und
justitiain hatte direkt gefeuert und
vorher schon angekündigt dass er die
moderationsregeln bei Twitter wieder
lockern möchte wen oder was er da
befreien möchte und welche Auswirkungen
das auf uns alle haben könnte das ist
heute unser Thema zu viel Macht für Musk
das ist die Frage und ihr könnt auch
Fragen stellen eben zu diesem Thema
kommentieren direkt im Stream oder per
Mail denn wir haben uns spannende Gäste
eingeladen dazu aber erstmal schauen wir
auf die Geschichte dieses Deals denn der
ist nicht SPON aus dem Nichts entstanden
sondern da gibt es eine Vergangenheit
und die hat Christian Volk für uns
zusammengefasst
dieses Video besiegelt wohl endgültig
die umstrittene Übernahme Elon Musk vor
zwei Tagen im Hauptsitz von Twitter in
San Francisco der Milliardär bekannt
geworden unter anderem mit seiner
e-automarke Tesla will mit dem Kauf laut
eigener Aussage gesunde Debatten möglich
machen
ich glaube dass Mast grundsätzlich in
der Lage wäre dem Unternehmen neues
Leben einzuhauchen aber in den letzten
Monaten hat sich so viel Misstrauen
zusammengebraut und es gab so viele
Turbulenzen bei Twitter dass ich mir
nicht mehr sicher bin ob das der Fall
ist die Turbulenzen beginnen am 4 April
mas kauft 9,2% von Twitter und zieht in
den Verwaltungsrat ein wenn ich später
provoziert er stellt Twitter öffentlich
in Frage die Folge doch kein Posten für
Musk Mitte April kündigt der 51-Jährige
an das gesamte Unternehmen kaufen zu
wollen für insgesamt 44 Milliarden
US-Dollar Twitter will den Kauf erst
verhindern stimmt wenig später aber doch
zu im Juli die Wände Musk will den Kauf
abblasen Grund der Kurznachrichtendienst
habe angeblich falsche Aussagen zur Zahl
der scheinkonten auf der Plattform
gemacht Twitter verklagt ihn will ihn
zwingen das Geschäft durchzuziehen vor
gut drei Wochen ändert mask erneut seine
Meinung er will Twitter nun doch kaufen
zum ursprünglich vereinbarten Preis
zuerst sprechen wir mit unserer
Korrespondentin in Washington mit
Alexandra havlen hallo
hallo Alisa
Alexandra die Reaktionen in Washington
jetzt auf diesen mega-dealer zwei Monate
gedauert aber heute eben endgültig
abgeschlossen wie waren die Reaktionen
gerade aus Washington
ist besorgt als Bedrohung für die
Demokratie haben es die Demokraten
genannt dass mask Twitter übernommen hat
mask ist der reichste Mann der Welt und
jetzt auch Besitzer einer der
einflussreichsten Plattformen also
Twitter kann wenn man sich die täglichen
Nutzer anguckt vielleicht nicht mit
Facebook Instagram oder tiktok mithalten
twitter hat täglich ungefähr
240 Millionen Nutzer aber gerade hier in
den USA wird Twitter vor allem von
Politikern und Journalisten verwendet
und trägt also hat er den großen
Einfluss auf die Meinungsbildung im Land
und
mittlerweile sieht man den Washington
sehr kritisch wie wie einflussreich und
wie rücksichtslos mask agieren kann ein
Demokrat ein demokratischer Senator hat
das ganz gut beschrieben den Einfluss
den mask auch auf die Menschen hat und
seine Follower seine über 100 Millionen
Follower auf Twitter er meinte die Leute
hängen an seinen Lippen eben weil er als
Milliardär als sehr erfolgreich gilt und
sie sie nehmen ihm eben jedes Wort ab
und er hofft dass sich mask dieser
Verantwortung jetzt noch mehr bewusst
wird und ihr entgegenkommt und es ist so
dass Maske in der Vergangenheit beide
Lager unterstützt hat die Demokraten und
die Republikaner auch finanziell aber in
in der kürzesten Zeit also es hat sich
jetzt mittlerweile ein bisschen geändert
er betreibt Bashing gegen die Regierung
beidens und hat auch schon angekündigt
dass er bei dem Präsidentschaftswahlen
2024 die Republikaner wählen wird und in
dem Sinne haben sich auch die
Republikaner heute positiv zu der
Übernahme Masken jetzt und unter Dach
und Fach ist geäußert Ted Cruisen
texanischer Senator hat hat gesagt das
heißt froh twitter ist jetzt in guten
Händen genau also je nachdem wie man
fragt in Washington unterschiedliche
Reaktionen ja spannend ist das ja auch
deshalb du hast die Wahl angesprochen
2024 aber in wenigen Tagen in der guten
Woche habt ihr mit terms also
zwischenwahl eine Art Stimmungstest für
die jetzige Regierung und natürlich dann
auch ein Ausblick wie es weitergeht und
das ist ja spannend weil bei der letzten
Wahl vor zwei Jahren mir erinnern uns
wurde ja die Lüge der gestohlenen Wahl
von den Ex-Präsident Trump verbreitet
auch über Twitter danach wurde er
gesperrt jetzt hat Elon Musk ja immer
wieder betont er ist ein Verfechter der
freien Rede er hält nichts davon
Accounts für immer zu verbannen und da
kommt jetzt auch die erste Frage zu
unserem Stream dazu viele fragen sich so
wie Felix bei Youtube heißt das denn
jetzt das Trump zurückkehrt auf Twitter
er hatte ja knapp 90 Millionen verloren
ja genau also das Verständnis mask von
der Redefreiheit ist so nach der Devise
alles geht fast alles geht und mask hat
auch in der Vergangenheit Twitter dafür
kritisiert dass man Trump ausgeschlossen
hat er hat sich vor Monaten dazu
geäußert hat gesagt es wäre eine
moralisch falsche Entscheidung gewesen
Trump auszuschließen er ist generell
sehr kritisch wenn es darum geht Profile
oder Personen dauerhaft zu blockieren
deshalb kann man erwarten dass Trump
vielleicht wieder auf die Plattform
zurückkehrt oder zumindest dazu
eingeladen wird weil Trump hat sich
gerade vor unserem Stream ich glaube
eine Stunde ist es her auf seiner
Plattform hat er sich dazu geäußert zu
Übernahme von Twitter durch mask und
Trump schreibt er auf true social dass
ich jetzt nicht direkt zitieren kann
aber
er sagt tschüss social hat sich als
Plattform e verliert und sei
erfolgreicher das sagt Trump als alle
anderen Plattformen auch als Twitter und
er ist froh dass Twitter jetzt in guten
Händen ist und nicht mehr in den Händen
und das ist ein trump-zitat von den
radikalinken wie er eben liberale oder
Demokraten nennt also die Frage ist will
Trump dann überhaupt zurück und das
nächste ist sollte Trump wieder auf
Twitter zurückkommen dann könnte es auch
andere Plattformen unter Druck setzen
zum Beispiel Facebook auch die haben
Trump gesperrt man könnte argumentieren
naja wenn er auf Twitter wieder
zugelassen ist warum lasst ihr ihn nicht
zu warum schränkt ihr da die
Redefreiheit ein über andere Plattformen
wie sowas auch wie true social sprechen
wir später in der Sendung noch aber noch
eine Frage zu den mitturms die er in
wenigen Tagen anstehen twitter hat da ja
in den letzten Wochen eigentlich schon
investiert also in Mitarbeitende die die
moderationsregeln kontrollieren sollen
gerade eben in die mitturms anstehen da
wieder die Gefahr besteht dass da Fake
News verbreitet werden könnten wollen
sie entgegenwirken auch wahrscheinlich
wieder mit Fake News lebe Label die sie
schon hatten faktenchecks und jetzt ist
die Frage gibt es dann aber Anzeichen
jetzt wo mask also dieser neue Chef von
Twitter ist dass er das umstoßen könnte
solche Pläne eben im Zuge seiner
Kampagne für mehr Redefreiheit wie er
das dann wahrscheinlich nennen wird
ja genau also wie du sagst die Mitte am
stehen ins Haus und es geht um vieles es
geht um die Mehrheit im Senat es geht um
die Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus und
Twitter hat so schon viel zu tun gerade
also es sind hunderte republikanische
Kandidaten die zu den Zwischenwahlen
antreten und die alle Trumps Lüge von
der gestohlenen Wahl 2020 vertreten
twitter ist wie du wie du es sagst da
hat sich eigens aufgestellt eine
Strategie die es schon seit 2018 gibt
und auch bei dem Präsidentschaftswahlen
2020 es gibt ein eine eigene election
Squad nennt sich das für Twitter also
ein Team freiwilliger Mitarbeitenden die
haben einen Crashkurs bekommen wie sie
gegen Fake News vorgehen wie sie Bots
schnell identifizieren die Propaganda
verbreiten und aber seit dem Deal
zwischen Musk und Twitter das läuft ja
schon seit Monaten wie wir es gehört
haben sind immer mehr Mitarbeiter haben
bereits gekündigt und ein hochrangiger
Whistleblower hat gesagt twitter hat
eigentlich jetzt schon nicht die
Ressourcen um die Richtlinien auf der
Plattform einhalten zu können und mask
hat zumindest in der Vergangenheit
angekündigt welche Pläne er ungefähr hat
für die Plattform er will die Plattform
profitabel machen und bis zu 75 also 75
Prozent der Belegschaft kündigen das hat
er also diese Woche jetzt vor zwei Tagen
wieder zurückgenommen als er in der
Zentrale war bei Twitter hat den
Mitarbeitenden versichert dass er das
nicht machen wollte aber das es bleibt
abzuwarten die Washington Post hat
angefragt bei Musk und bei der
twittersprecherin wann denn diese Pläne
dass die Moderation auf Twitter
eingeschränkt wird und so weiter wann
diese Pläne denn umgesetzt werden sollen
und darauf gab es bisher keine
Reaktionen aber wenn man dem Glauben
schenkt hat zum Beispiel ein
republikanischer Senator sich heute
geäußert auf Twitter hat gesagt er war
bis vor kurzem auf Twitter ausgeloggt
konnte sich nicht einloggen und heute
kann er Twitter wieder verwenden also
dass wenn das wahr ist dann ist es ein
Indiz dafür dass eine neue
Ära für Twitter angebrochen ist sagt
Alexandra haflin Einschätzung live aus
Washington danke dafür
und wir haben auch euch gefragt was
haltet ihr von diesem Deal im Community
Tab vorher schon bei Youtube und
Sonnenberg zu Fuß hat geschrieben habe
mein Twitter-Account deaktiviert sehe
das mit mask kritisch und bin jetzt auch
wieder bei Mastodon dazu noch später
übrigens mehr in der Sendung an dieser
Stelle seines gesagt wir haben aber auch
Stimmen wie zum Beispiel von petruschki
der schreibt der Twitter Kauf von Elon
Musk ist ein Gewinn für die Demokratie
sowie die Meinungsfreiheit und wir
können jetzt noch weiter über dieses
Thema sprechen das noch ein bisschen
intensiver behandeln aber ich habe es
eben auch schon kurz angesprochen in
diesem Kommentar es gibt natürlich auch
jetzt schon Stimmen die sagen warum
nicht ausweichen auf eine andere
Plattform wer weiß und wir haben dazu
auch was vorbereitet es ist im besonders
Mastodon die Plattform im Gespräch und
manche User überlegen ob sie eben von
Twitter weggehen zu einer Plattform wie
dieser und was das genau ist das hat uns
Moritz neues erstmal erklärt
wenn aus tweeten Tröten wird dann sind
wir bei Mastodon das werbefreien
Netzwerk will Twitter-Nutzern eine neue
Alternative Plattform bieten mit Mammut
statt Vogel ins Leben gerufen hat den
Microblogging Dienst ein deutscher
Softwareentwickler Eugen Rochow
finanziert durch Spenden das unabhängige
Netzwerk verfolgt keine finanziellen
Absichten und ist im Gegensatz zu
Twitter dezentral organisiert das heißt
es besteht aus zahlreichen Servern sie
werden unter anderem von Privatpersonen
und gemeinnützigen Organisationen
Betrieben im Prinzip funktioniert
Mastodon nicht anders als Twitter die
tröds statt Tweets können von anderen
Nutzerinnen und Nutzern kommentiert
geteilt oder favorisiert werden einer
der Knackpunkte während bei Twitter ein
Algorithmus beim Suchen und Finden von
Personen und Zeiten mit ähnlichen
Interessen hilft ist hier Eigenregie
angesagt doch noch ist Masteron ein
Zwerg seit seiner Gründung 2016 hat das
Netzwerk 5,7 Millionen Nutzerinnen und
Nutzer gewonnen eine nischencommunity
zum Vergleich twitter hat über 436
Millionen Nutzer
und wir können jetzt noch mehr Fragen
stellen an Professor Matthias
zekettemann von der Uni Innsbruck denn
er ist Professor für Innovation und
Internet Governance und heute für uns
für unsere Fragen da schönen guten Abend
guten Abend wir haben es gerade gehört
ein User aus unserem aus unserer
Community überlegte schon Mastodon ist
das ein wirklich eine Alternative wie
schätzen Sie das denn ein also der
Beitrag hat ja auch gerade schon
anklingen lassen es ist ein Zwerg wie
realistisch ist das denn überhaupt dass
viele sich jetzt umorientieren könnten
und so eine Plattform wie Mastodon dann
Erfolgschancen hätte
alle Plattformen haben als Zwerge
begonnen ich halte Master dann weil es
ein dezentrales Netzwerk ist das auf dem
auf den auf der Energie auf der
Kreativität verschiedener Userinnen und
User beruht für eine sehr
zukunftsträchtige Plattform sie kommt
aus Deutschland hier haben wir also
wirklich die Chance entgegenmodell zu
entwickeln dass mehr im öffentlichen
Interesse orientiert ist und nicht an
der privaten Gewinnerzielungsabsicht
twitter facebook tiktok die werden alle
beherrscht von Leuten die Geld machen
wollen und entsprechend schauen dann
auch die Kommunikationsregeln auf diesem
Plattformen aus da ist Mastodon eine
gute Alternative es braucht noch ein
bisschen Wumms also ein bisschen
Energie bis eine kritische Masse an
NutzerInnen erreicht ist
und schauen wir jetzt aber noch mal auf
natürlich den super Deal von heute und
deswegen sprechen wir ja überhaupt über
die Chancen wie über so eine Plattform
wie machst du dann was glauben Sie denn
was hat Elon Musk konkret mit Twitter
vor was ist da ihre Einschätzung
wenn man sich anschaut was macht mit
Unternehmen
zum Mars fliegen eine tolle neue
Bohrmaschine bauen
er ist ein kreativer Ingenieur er möchte
Lösungen finden und er möchte auch damit
Geld verdienen und ich glaube er wird
aus twittern etwas machen was
was ihm ermöglicht neue neue
Perspektiven neue Welten zu erobern wie
macht man das naja zum Beispiel indem er
Twitter erweitert um einen Bezahldienst
oder Twitter integriert in eine Art
umfassendes Kommunikationsnetzwerk
vielleicht werden wir bald Twitter haben
dass mit Autos kommuniziert mit seinen
Tesla Fahrzeugen er wird also
wahrscheinlich neue Wege zur
Monetarisierung suchen und finden
vielleicht auch im Kontext des metavers
dass er vielleicht nicht ganz Facebook
überlassen möchte
gestern hat er sich ja schon in einer
Art offenem Brief das war also auch ein
Tweet den er da geteilt hat an die
Werbekunden gewandt und da hat er um
Vertrauen für seinen Kurs geworben und
ich zitiere mal ein paar Stellen schrieb
also Twitter dürfe kein Ort des Grauens
werden wo ohne Konsequenzen alles gesagt
werden können das hatte erklärt die
Plattform müsse Zitat warm und einladend
für alle sein er hätte Twitter nicht
gekauft weil es einfach weil es einfach
sein würde oder weil er mehr Geld machen
will hat er noch weiter geschrieben und
auch hier Zitat ich tat es um der
Menschheit zu helfen die ich liebe es
ist jetzt Elon Musk natürlich nicht
bekannten Rainer Wohltäter zu sein
sondern es vor allem Geschäftsmann aber
warum hat er jetzt ausgerechnet so eine
Art der Message an seine Werbekunden
gewählt
wenn er schon auch ein Geschäftsmann ist
und das ist auch die Message die an die
Werbekunden geht ne die denen wieder
sagen ihr braucht keine große Angst
haben ich werde hier also nicht alle
alle Regeln für Meinungsäußerungen
runterfahren mit dem Ergebnis dass das
eine ein großes Schlamassel wird ein ein
Sumpf von Hassrede und Desinformation wo
keiner mehr eine Werbung schalten möchte
nach für eine Richtung sagte also liebe
Leute das wird jetzt ein Ort der
Freiheit ihr könnt sagen was ihr wollt
aber die Leute die 95% des Budgets
zahlen die Werbekunden den versichert er
ich werde schon schauen dass es ein Ort
ist wo ihr gerne Werbung schaltet und wo
ihr auch weiterhin gerne euer Geld
ausgeben sollte
er hat ja außerdem gesagt ich habe es am
Anfang der Sendung auch zitiert er hätte
den Vogel befreit mit Anspielungen
natürlich auf das Logo von Twitter er
hat darauf auch heute schon Antworten
bekommen zum Beispiel vom
eu-industriekommissar theorieprinton der
schrieb daraufhin in Europa wird der
Vogel nach unseren EU-Regeln fliegen und
vielleicht ist das mal ein wichtiger
Punkt auf dem wir schauen müssen
Unterschiede USA Europa was heißt denn
dieser Deal und was da vielleicht an
Änderungen ansteht überhaupt konkret für
uns hier in Europa
wir werden recht wenig davon merken weil
die europäischen Staaten haben schon vor
einiger Zeit beschlossen dass sie die
Plattformen mehr Regeln unterwerfen
wollen so gilt in Deutschland das
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz das verlangt
jetzt schon von Plattformen bestimmte
Inhalte je nach Schwere der der Online
verübten Tat Beleidigung Drohung
Morddrohung entweder innerhalb von 24
Stunden oder in etwas längerer Zeit zu
löschen darauf darüber hinaus müssen sie
noch bestimmte Transparenzberichte
abgeben und generell einfach dafür
sorgen dass ihre Online-Plattform
einigermaßen nach Recht und regeln dass
das dort herrscht das ist in Amerika
ganz anders in Amerika dürfen die
Plattformen im Wesentlichen machen was
sie wollen sie können löschen wenn sie
wollen sie können rauswerfen wenn Sie
wollen und die europäische NutzerInnen
Nutzer sind in gewisser Weise in einem
rechtsstaatlichen Paradies auch wenn Sie
das manchmal nicht zum anfühlt und
gerade jetzt auch mit dem europäischen
Recht das da angesprochen wurde wird
sich einiges tun
2024 kommt ein neuer Rechtsakt jener
über digitale Dienste die SA heißt der
und der wird die Plattformen und auch
Twitter noch einmal stärker an an das
Recht binden wir müssen dann sogar
erklären wie ihre
empfehlungsalgorithmen funktionieren
also wer welche Inhalte bekommt die
müssen Risiko assessments abgeben sie
müssen erklären wie sie auf die
Demokratie wirken da kommt auch ein Elon
Musk nicht drumherum und er hat auch so
vor drei vier Monaten sich mal getroffen
mit dem tierebritanne ein Video das auf
Youtube abrufbar ist wo er sogar
bestätigt ja ja er will sich schon an
das europäische Recht halten genauso wie
ihr auch sondern Werbekunden bestätigt
ja er wird ja schon dafür sorgen dass
das nicht zu schlimm wird
dazu aber gleich eine Frage bei uns aus
dem Stream da möchte der User chriswords
wissen wird das
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz überhaupt
auf Plattformen wie Twitter
ja das wirkt Twitter Facebook und und
die anderen traditionelleren Plattformen
haben sich recht gut eingestellt auf das
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz die eine
Plattform die Widerstand leistet und
sich nicht daran hält ist das telegram
aber twitter hat sich in der
Vergangenheit in der Regel gut daran
gehalten die deutschen Gerichte haben
auch dieses Gesetz und auch andere
entsprechend ausgelegt und auch
bestätigt dass die Plattformen gebunden
sind an diese Regeln auch wenn sie
innerhalb des staatlichen rechts immer
noch viel Freiheit haben zu entscheiden
was online bleiben darf und was sie
unternehmen wollen
weil sie gerade ist ja so ein bisschen
verglichen haben gesagt haben wir hätten
paradiesische Zustände meine ich haben
sie gesagt in Europa im Vergleich zu den
USA aber viele NutzerInnen Nutzer nehmen
ja trotzdem viel Hass und Hetze eben auf
der Plattform war also
kontrolliert da jetzt irgendjemand
überhaupt noch dann was was da passiert
also ist so jemand wie Elon Musk der
dann die Macht in sich vereint überhaupt
zu kontrollieren wird das mehr wird das
weniger mit Hass und Hetze bei Twitter
dann jetzt künftig
es gibt natürlich auch im
deutschsprachigen Internet auf den
deutschsprachigen Plattformen ein
unzumutbares Maß an Headset die auch wir
wissen das ja überschwappt in in reale
Gewalt gegen diese gegen diese Hassrede
gegen Desinformationen muss mit den
Mittel des Rechts oder mit den Mitteln
der Plattform Regeln vorgegangen werden
keine Frage aber da wird sich nicht viel
ändern nur jetzt da da Twitter einen
neuen Eigentümer hat innerhalb von
Deutschland gibt es jetzt schon
bestimmte
gute und wichtige zivilgesellschaftliche
Organisationen wie hate aid die
Eintreten für einen besseren eine
bessere Rechtsdurchsetzung online ist
allen anzuraten die hassräder sehen die
zu melden die Beweise zu sichern sie
anzuzeigen die Polizei wird immer
effektiver darin online Verbrechen zu
verfolgen hast du Rede zu verfolgen das
ist eine gesellschaftliche Aufgabe
genauso wie wir alle wenn wir in der
Stadt spazieren gehen links und rechts
schauen ob es wohl also wenn es uns wenn
ihr was sehen was uns nicht gefällt dann
sagen wir was dasselbe muss auch in der
Onlinewelt gelten die gehört uns allen
wir alle müssen die neu gestalten das
heißt auf Master dann oder das heißt auf
den klassischen Plattformen wie meine
große Verantwortung auch eine
Verantwortung gegenüber der nächsten
Generation eine
demokratische
kommunikationsordnung eine
Kommunikationsraum zu sichern um
Zusammenhalt zu sichern auch für die
nächste Generation
trotzdem noch eine Frage aus dem Stream
dazu das interessiert dann doch einige
und zwar wie soll das europäische Recht
denn durchgesetzt werden wie wird das
geprüft und Europa und Europa denn
überhaupt ein Hebel zu Durchsetzung also
hat Europa denn überhaupt einen Hebel
zur Durchsetzung
also die der neue europäische Recht sagt
wird durchgesetzt durch sogenannte
digital Service Koordinators also für
Koordinatoren für digitale Dienste die
wird in jedem Land geben in Deutschland
wird gerade geschaut welche Rolle welche
Institution diese Rolle übernimmt
vielleicht die Bundesnetzagentur
vielleicht die Landesmedienanstalten und
die muss diese Verpflichtungen der
Plattformen kontrollieren wenn die
Plattformen etwa zu wenig Hassrede
löschen oder die Berichte die sie
abgeben müssen nicht abgeben können sie
bestraft werden mit teilsempfindlichen
Strafen die können gehen bis hin zu
einer Zerschlagung des Unternehmens
es gibt nämlich nicht nur den digital
services Act also diesen Rechtsakt es
gibt auch andere Rechtsakte etwa einer
über digitale Märkte also wenn sich ein
Unternehmen zum Beispiel
wettbewerbswidrig verhält und dann noch
nicht ausreichend die Inhalte moderiert
die problematisch sind können diese
Behörden dann auf nationaler Ebene
durchstrafen und schlussendlich auch
durch Verbote hier die Plattformen an
das recht erinnern und dieses
durchsetzungsinstrumentarium ist viel
effektiver ausgestaltet als das aktuelle
schon jetzt kann das
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz durchgesetzt
werden durch das Bundesamt für Justiz
das ist in der Vergangenheit allerdings
nicht sehr erfolgreich geklappt
gehen wir noch mal einen Schritt weiter
wir haben gesagt uns allen gehört ja der
öffentliche Raum im Internet sage ich
mal aber es gibt ja nicht nur Elon Musk
auch andere Superreiche die sich also
Plattformen kaufen wir hatten es am
Anfang der Sendung auch schon
angesprochen Donald Trump der ehemalige
US-Präsident hatte sich nach dem Thema
gesperrt wurde bei Twitter also true
social eine Art Twitter Klonen selbst
gegründet Kanye West der Rapper der sich
jetzt je nennt der will die Plattform
Pala eventuell kaufen wie ist das denn
zu bewerten wenn also ein paar wenige
Superreiche dann diese Plattform neu
gründen oder besitzen und das dann quasi
also in den Händen von ein paar wenigen
Superreichen ist was ja natürlich klar
mit mit suckerberg und Co auch jetzt
schon der Fall war
das halte ich für sehr sehr kritisch
das ist zuckerburger ansprechen ist ist
ein guter Punkt es war ja schon bisher
so dass Plattformen regelmäßig in der
Hand von von nur wenigen Reichen Männern
waren und das ist sehr problematisch
weil die Plattformen sind das was wir
heutzutage an an öffentlichem Raum im
Internet haben und es ist kein
öffentlicher Raum sondern private
Kommunikationsräume die gehören diesen
reichen Leuten die können die Regeln
setzen es hat lange gedauert bis die
Staaten der Welt das erkannt haben und
durch diese erwähnten Gesetze versucht
haben hier ein bisschen korrigierender
einzugreifen man muss einfach sagen wir
und die Staaten haben verschlafen dass
hier einige wenige Reiche Menschen
Plattformen schaffen in denen wir online
kommunizieren nach deren Regeln
optimiert auf deren Ziele nämlich uns
möglichst lange online zu halten um uns
viele Werbungen zu zeigen das heißt ich
sehe das als sehr problematisch
allerdings sind Verbote der regelmäßig
nicht eine gute Lösung auch die
Zerschlagung ist ist nicht sinnvoll weil
die
Versäumnisse der letzten Jahres sollten
nicht durch überschießende Maßnahmen
heute weitergemacht werden viel sind
voller ist es sich zu überlegen wie
können wir erstens Alternativen aufbauen
wie machst du dann und wie können wir
zweitens die Kommunikationsräume
demokratischer gestalten wie können wir
also die Regeln von Twitter von Facebook
von tiktok besser rückbinden an
gesellschaftliche Werte durch
plattformparlamente zum Beispiel oder
durch plattformbeiräte das halte ich für
eine sehr vielversprechende Entwicklung
einige der Plattformen arbeiten schon
daran wir sollten hier auf jeden Fall
weiter denken um eben sicherzustellen
dass der Ort wo wir kommunizieren unsere
Meinung bilden unsere Meinung äußern
dass diese Orte unter der Regeln von
Regeln bestimmt werden die nicht nur
privaten Interessen dienen sondern im
öffentlichen Wohl
die Stimmung bei uns im Chat das ganz
unterschiedlich ich möchte es kurz
bisschen Vorlesen um da damit wir auch
wissen was er damit Sie auch wissen was
da geschrieben wird zum einen schreibt
Julian Shaquille bei Facebook ich freue
mich so sehr Elon Musk ist ein sehr
verantwortungsvoller Mensch es kann nur
bergauf gehen mit beides kann nur
bergauf gehen mit Twitter Peter Schütz
bei Facebook der schreibt eine andere
Richtung wenn tech-konzerne mächtiger
sind als Regierung sollte man sie
zerschlagen also da auch ein bisschen
eine kritische Stimme ganz
unterschiedliche Meinungen hier was
natürlich auch in spannender Punkt ist
wenn wir beim Thema macht und wie
mächtig jemand ist sind natürlich was
man bekommt wenn man in der Eigentümer
von Twitter ist ist vor allem Daten also
wer klickt was wer teilt was wer
interessiert sich wofür und diese Daten
die jetzt Elon Muskeln damit auch
bekommt wenn ja gesammelt in
Datenzentren bei Twitter da ist
natürlich die Frage was hat er damit vor
als Geschäftsmann der ja auch noch
andere Unternehmen und andere Interessen
hat was ist da ihre Einschätzung
er hat Elon Musk ist ein großer Fan von
Daten streng genommen ist der Tesla auch
nicht wirklich ein ein Autounternehmen
sondern ein Daten Unternehmen
das künstlichen Intelligenz immer besser
macht um dann irgendwann einmal ein
richtiger autonomes Auto zu schaffen es
besteht es ist wohl zu erwarten dass er
Facebook auf jeden Fall auch anzapft um
Produkte besser zu besser zu machen
besser auf die
Bedürfnisse der Kundinnen und Kunden
abzustellen ich denke aber auch dass wir
hier dass er vor der Herausforderung
stehen wird aber sich an das
Datenschutzrecht hält was regelmäßig
verbietet zwischen Unternehmen die nicht
zusammengehören einfach Nutzerdaten zu
übertragen er wird das wahrscheinlich
nicht so genau sehen weil die alle ihm
gehören allerdings wird hier das
europäische Datenschutzrecht eben einen
großen diesem hervor schieben das heißt
die der Vogel ist nicht nur an das an
das Recht gebunden das noch kommt mit
dem DSA sondern bestehendes
Datenschutzrecht er kann nicht einfach
Daten aus Twitter absaugen er kann sie
aber innerhalb von Twitter verwenden um
zum Beispiel zu schauen wie etwa die
Integration einer einer Wallet also
einer Online
Bezahlfunktion in Twitter ankommen würde
es wird auch erwartet dass ich erwarte
auch dass er die die empfehlungs
Algorithmen von Twitter also die
Instrumente die uns die Inhalte erst
bringen dass er die wahrscheinlich noch
ein bisschen Nachschärfen wird auf
Grundlage einer besseren Nutzung der
bestehenden Daten
ja und Twitter auch vielleicht anhand
natürlich von solchen Daten oder
insgesamt mal drauf geguckt Twitter
verstärkt Meinungen kann ja auch
Diskurse lenken sehen sie da eine Gefahr
dass also das jetzt irgendwie noch
stärker werden könnte oder sagen Sie es
bleibt alles gleich
ja man muss da immer ein bisschen
aufpassen weil es sehr schwierig ist
nachzuweisen wo wie genau jetzt ein
Diskurs gelenkt wird und wo der herkommt
zum Beispiel die Diskussion um um das
winneto-buch eines deutschen Verlages
das dann zurückgezogen wurde der konnte
nachgewiesen werden dass diese
Diskussion vor der Berichterstattung in
den Offline Medien online praktisch
nicht geführt wurde und erst dann als
die Bild-Zeitung darüber berichtete
wurde das dann medial zu einem größeren
Thema also online zu einem größeren
Thema war das dann die Offline Zeitung
die das bewirkt hat oder wann das die
Medien über das die die Internet
NutzerInnen
nicht immer so einig in der Tat aber ist
es so dass Twitter sie haben es vorher
immer anspannen angesprochen twitter hat
eine sehr große und über ihre
Nutzerzahlen hinausgehen der Wirkung
aufgrund der starken Präsenz von
Menschen aus Politik Medien und aus der
Wissenschaft
und da ist schon zu erwarten dass es
weiterhin so eine Rolle spielen wird
gerade weil es jetzt noch einmal so
stark in den Mittelpunkt rückt und sehr
viele Leute darauf schauen was macht ihr
denn Master damit und wie wird er das
Produkt weiterentwickeln denn es ist und
das ist leider so es ist ein Produkt es
ist ein ein etwas was ihm gehört und er
kann damit vieles machen und
gleichzeitig ist es aber auch eine
Kommunikationsplattform wo hunderte
Millionen Menschen Inhalte produzieren
teilen und Meinungen bilden diese
private Wert des private Eigentum an
ganzen
kommunikationsordnungen und
Kommunikation zu räumen ist eine große
Herausforderung unserer Zeit der Art und
Weise wie wir das Internet heute haben
und da sind dann Produkte Projekte wie
Wikipedia oder eben wie machst du dann
ganz wichtige und nötige
Neuorientierungen auf das Gemeinwohl weg
von einer reinen Gewinnorientierung
clash of me bringt da noch die
Perspektive mit rein der User bei
Youtube Datenauswertung ist ja
persönlich schlecht ist solange er das
nicht rein aus Profitmaximierung macht
Praxis Maximierung macht sondern auch
das Allgemeinwohl im Blick hat zum
Schluss würde mich noch die Frage
interessieren denn Maske hat auch immer
wieder angedeutet dass er vielleicht
auch mehr Pläne noch für Twitter hat das
daraus vielleicht also noch ein viel
größeres Netzwerk entstehen könnte eine
App für alles so wurde es mal genannt
glauben Sie dass das realistisch ist was
genau könnte das sein
also bei Elon Muster da darf man
durchaus sich ein bisschen gespannt sein
auf das was kommt wenn man sich überlegt
wie schnell es zum
zum
Weltall ging wie effektive zum Beispiel
bei der Ukraine schnell geholfen hat
internationen zu schaffen und jetzt
seine Mars Pläne da ist glaube ich eine
Integration von von anderen Angeboten
innerhalb von von Twitter nicht dass das
schwierigste das ist nämlich auch ein
ingenieuring-problem ne also das ist ein
Problem dass er lösen kann die
Meinungsäußerungsfreiheit die kann er
nicht lösen das wird jeden Tag ein neues
Problem werden und eins woran er glaube
ich keine Freude hat es ist gut wenn er
fokussiert auf eine Erweiterung des
Produkts des von Twitter zu einer ja
umfassenden Plattform da bin ich sehr
gespannt was wir das sehen werden
vielleicht kommt als erste Entwicklung
eine Art vernetztes Auto Twitter wo also
alle Teslas miteinander kommunizieren
können das Internet der Dinge ist ein
großes Thema der Zukunft Kommunikation
zu Rob sind immer wichtiger also ich
kann mir gut vorstellen dass in diese
Richtung einige Innovationen von eben
noch noch kommen werden sagt Professor
Matthias C hätte man vielen Dank dass
Sie bei uns zu Gast waren danke sehr
und danke auch an euch für die vielen
Fragen und dass ihr zugeschaut habt und
ich fand einen Kommentar von Rusty
shackle fort der oder die dich gar nicht
mal so sehr für das Thema Twitter
interessiert hat für uns zum Schluss
aber noch ganz interessant und zwar
schrieb er oder sie das Leben findet
nicht nur im Internet statt und das
stimmt und deswegen euch allen ein
schönes Wochenende und bis zum nächsten
Mal tschüss